So the next time a man insults you,
what I want you to do is instead of receive that and, like,
internalize it,
realize
what they're doing is pointing out something that makes you unique
and different from other people,
whatever it is.
Like, they love to call me a great old lady,
but the amount of men that fucking drool
when they see a little bit of grain.
Oh, she's a mature woman,
you know what I mean?
There is somebody that finds you, you, exactly how you are attractive.
You can watch the show my 600 pound life
and see that every single one of those people
with all of their
not just physical differences.
And I'm not saying that fat is ugly and skinny is pretty.
What I'm saying is
there's just so many examples of couples that you're like, wow,
I never would have thought that person would have, like,
a capacity to have a romantic relationship in their life
with everything else they have going on.
Like there's that couple, squirmy and grubs.
Um, just like,
there's gonna be somebody that loves you when you love yourself.
When you realize you are beautiful.
The things that make you a little bit different
that people are pointing out,
those are the things that make you beautiful.
So you're a little bit rounder.
So many people love that.
The skinny girls wish they could put on a little bit more weight.
The heavier girls wish they could Lose a little bit of weight.
The curly girls straighten their hair.
The girls with straight hair spend their time curling their hair.
Like, just literally embrace the things that make you you
and watch how fucking happy you get.